NOW, THIS LATEST DEVELOPMENT,
WHICH WE'LL BRING YOU DETAILS ON
SHORTLY, COMES ONLY TWO DAYS
AFTER HE BECAME THE FIRST
CURRENT OR FORMER PRESIDENT EVER
TO BE HIT WITH A SEARCH WARRANT.
AND JUST HOURS AFTER BECOMING
THE FIRST EVER TO INVOKE HIS
FIFTH AMENDMENT RIGHT AGAINST
SELF-INCRIMINATION, WHICH IS A
PILLAR OF CIVIL LIBERTIES, BUT
WHICH HE USED TO SAY ONLY
MOBSTERS DO, UNTIL HE TOOK THE
FIFTH AND SAYING WHAT ONLY
MOBSTERS SAY WHEN EVER THEY'RE
SEARCHED, IN THIS CASE
SUGGESTING WITHOUT ANYTHING AT
ALL TO BACK IT UP, THAT FEDERAL
AGENTS PLANTED EVIDENCE WHEN
THEY SEARCHED MAR-A-LAGO ON
MONDAY, WHICH THEN QUICKLY
BECAME A REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINT, OR IN THE CASE OF LINDSEY
GRAHAM, SENATOR GRAHAM, WHO SITS
ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
WHO CLEARLY SHOULD KNOW BETTER,
JUST ANOTHER TOXIC IDEA TO SMILE
AND NOT ALONG WITH.
>> WE KNOW THEY DOCTOR EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW THEY PLANT EVIDENCE.
>> SURE.
>> WE KNOW THEY HIDE EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW THEY LIE.
WE KNOW THEY LEAK.
I MEAN THIS IS NOT ANYTHING NEW.
THIS HAS BEEN -- THIS HAS BEEN
YEARS THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS.
WE CAN'T JUST SAY, OH, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE GUY TO
COME OUT AND GIVE A STATEMENT
ABOUT WHAT IS PREDICATED -- I
MEAN, WHAT?
THESE PEOPLE ARE OUT OF CONTROL,
SENATOR.
THIS COUNTRY IS AT, LIKE --
WE'RE ON THE EDGE OF A CLIFF,
MAN.
I'M TELLING YOU, THIS COUNTRY IS
AT THE EDGE OF A CLIFF HERE.
>> NOW, AGAIN, THAT'S A MEMBER
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
A CHAMPION, LIKE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CLAIMS TO BE, OF LAW
AND ORDER, LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> A LOT OF NORMS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OBVIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN UPENDED FOR A LONG TIME
NOW, BUT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
TRADITIONALLY TOUTED ITS
DEDICATION TO LAW AND ORDER.
SO HAVE YOU BEEN SURPRISED AT
ALL TO HEAR -- OR TO SEE LINDSEY
GRAHAM SORT OF SMILING AND
NODDING AND AGREEING WITH A FOX
NEWS HOST TALKING ABOUT PLANTING
EVIDENCE AND OTHER REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, SOUNDING AS
IF -- I MEAN FOR OBVIOUS VERY
POLITICAL REASONS, I'M NOT SURE
THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT, BUT
WHO ARE ALL BACKING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IN HIS OUTRAGE?
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM, A MEMBER OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
HE IS A SHAMEFUL, DISGRACEFUL,
APPALLING COWARD, AND HE KNOWS
AS WELL AS ANYONE THAT IT'S
RIDICULOUS TO ASSERT THAT THE
FBI PLANTED EVIDENCE HERE, OKAY?
AND HE WAS JUST -- IT WAS JUST A
REMARKABLE DISPLAY EVEN FOR HIM
OF COWARDICE TO SIT THERE AND
NOD AND SAY, OH, YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH.
HE KNOWS BETTER, AND THEY ALL
KNOW BETTER.
TODAY IT'S BECOME FASHIONABLE IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL AND APPALLING
TO BASICALLY ATTACK LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN IT IS GOING
AFTER PEOPLE THEY LIKE AND TO
PRAISE IT WHEN THEY GO AFTER
PEOPLE THEY DON'T LIKE.
THAT'S NOT HOW THE RULE OF LAW
WORKS.
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM KNOWS THAT AS
WELL AS ANYBODY, BUT HE'S TOO --
HE'S TOO COWARDLY TO ADMIT IT IN
THIS CASE.
>> THERE'S ALSO, YOU KNOW,
THREATS OF CIVIL WAR FROM
FAR-RIGHT GROUPS.
THE REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
COMPARING THE FBI TO THE
GESTAPO, TELLING AMERICANS
THEY'RE COMING FOR YOU TOO.
IT CERTAINLY SEEMS DANGEROUS FOR
ANYBODY TO BE USING THAT KIND OF
RHETORIC, WHETHER YOU'RE ON THE
RIGHT OR THE LEFT, FOR WHATEVER
REASON, GIVEN THE VIOLENCE WE
SAW ON JANUARY 6th.
>> RIGHT.
I MEAN, WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST
FEDERAL JUDGES KILLED, NOT THAT
MANY FORTUNATELY, AND WE'VE
HAD -- A COUPLE YEARS AGO, THERE
WAS A FEDERAL JUDGE IN NEW
JERSEY WHOSE FAMILY MEMBER WAS
KILLED.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THE
POTENTIAL FOR CONCERTED ATTACKS
ON THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM, AND THAT
KIND OF LANGUAGE, THAT KIND OF
THREAT IS -- IS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS THINGS YOU CAN HAVE IN
A DEMOCRACY IN A FREE COUNTRY.
IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
SEE WHEN DEMOCRACIES COLLAPSE.
AND WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO STAND UP FOR THE JUDGES.
AND, REMEMBER, A LOT OF -- YOU
KNOW, ON JANUARY 6th, THE REASON
WHY TRUMP'S ATTEMPTED COUP
FAILED WAS IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE JUDICIARY, STATE AND FEDERAL
JUDGES FROM COAST TO COAST,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
INCLUDING TRUMP APPOINTEES TO
THE FEDERAL BENCH STOOD UP AND
STRUCK DOWN DONALD TRUMP'S
MERITLESS CLAIMS THAT THERE WAS
ELECTION FRAUD.
AND IT'S JUST MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES TODAY,
THROUGH THE COWARDICE AND THE
SHAMELESSNESS OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, THAT WE STAND UP FOR THE
RULE OF LAW AND STAND UP FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ENFORCE THE LAW AND
APPLY THE LAW -- THE JUDGES.
AND THANKFULLY CONGRESS, ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS, ADDED TO THE
PROTECTION OF THE JUDICIARY
RECENTLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
THREAT MADE AGAINST JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH.
WE NEED TO DO MORE OF THAT, AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANYBODY THAT THESE THREATS ARE
INVESTIGATED THOROUGHLY AND THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THEM ARE
PROSECUTED.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS HAS REALLY
STRENGTHENED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S STANDING IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> I THINK IT MAY HAVE
STRENGTHENED HIS STANDING AMONG
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE PARTY.
I THINK THAT, AGAIN, WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS IT PROVIDES ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TO ACT LIKE
COWARDS, AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAS REACHED THE DEBASED LEVELS
THAT IT HAS REACHED TODAY.
THAT BEING SAID, I DON'T
THINK -- I DON'T THINK FOR MOST
AMERICANS, WHO DON'T SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP BLINDLY, WHICH IS
WHY DONALD TRUMP LOST BY
7.5 MILLION VOTES IN THE LAST
ELECTION -- I THINK FOR MOST
AMERICANS, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
APPALLED BY THESE THREATS TO OUR
DEMOCRACY AND TO THE JUDICIARY
AND TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> GEORGE CONWAY, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.